اخبر العالم بايجاز بغرفه اخبار الجزيره
اهلا بكم في خطابه السنوي امام الجمعيات
البرلمانيه بوتين يقول ان روسيا تواجه
خطرا وجوديا ويعلن تعليق المشاركه في
معاهده ستارت للحد من الاسلحه
الاستراتيجيه واشنطن تصف القرار بغير
المسؤول وبايدن يؤكد من وارسو ان دعم
بلاده لاوكرانيا لا يتزعزع وان النيتو
اصبح اقوى من اي وقت مضى
مع اشتداد المعارك في محور بخبوت شرقي
اوكرانيا الجيش الاوكراني يؤكد انه صد
محاولات التقدم الروسيه في محيط المدينه
الاستراتيجيه
وقائد ميليشيات فاجنر يتهم من سماهم
معرقليه الانتصار بحرمالي مقاتله من
الذخيره ويصف الامر بالخيانه
سته قتله ومئات جرحى في زلزلي هاتاي
الجديدين الجنوبي تركيا الاف العائلات
تخلى منازلها شماليه سوريا خوفا من
انهيارات جديده والامم المتحده تقدر عددا
معتمدين على الدعم الانساني بشمال سوريا
باكثر من 4 ملايين وتجدد مطالبتها بتسهيل
وصول المساعدات
وسط حمله اعتقالات شامله شخصيات سياسيه
ونقابيه في تونس زعيم حركه النهضه ورئيس
البرلمان المنحل يخضع للتحقيق فيما يعرف
بقضيه تكفير الامنيين والغنوشي يتهم ما
وصفه بالانقلاب باستهداف كافه الكيالات
الوطنيه
الى اللقاء